it comes in the night causing mischief
and preying on unsuspecting sleepers in
their beds
it may even drink your blood no I'm not
talking about Dracula but something a
little bit more mysterious the Tokoloshe
often described as a goblin light
creature whose sole purpose is to cause
mischief and hardship for humans this
notorious South African monster is
blamed for everything from theft to
divorce also called a ticklish many
believe it is real even elevating their
beds off of the ground to avoid becoming
a victim of this diminutive creature the
majority of people have never claimed to
see one but if something goes wrong in
South Africa you can bet a Tokoloshe is
to blame i'm dr. emily szarka and this
is monstrum
first off let's talk about pronunciation
there are a number of different ways you
can pronounce this monster's name
Tokoloshe tokuyoshi Tokoloshe a and many
more but to keep it consistent I'm going
to use one of the most common versions
Tokoloshe reports of the Tokoloshe
appear in the news quite often sometimes
for something as simple as stealing food
but other times it's said to be the
cause of more serious crimes in 1933 a
man went to jail for the murder of his
nephew whom he had mistakenly killed
after miss identifying him as a
Tokoloshe there's even a movie about it
with all the different varieties of the
Tokoloshe i found in my research i have
to admit i caught a little confused
so i was thrilled when i was able to
talk to a sangoma a sangoma or in
sangoma is a south african traditional
healer who is believed to be called by
the ancestors to enter into this
essential role these people often have
common jobs like teaching or law but
they also serve their communities as
physical and spiritual healers divin
aiders and protectors against witchcraft
sangoma Musa fook-la confirmed that
there are different types of Tokoloshe
but the basic description is a short
powerful half-human half-animal being
that feeds off of the dark energy
created by harassing humans they are
active at night and are almost always
small hairy goblin like creatures some
say they have long ears maybe even a
tail the one thing they all have in
common is some kind of relationship with
a witch in South Africa someone capable
of people may be suspected to be a witch
and harm can come to a person if they
are characterized this way a Tokoloshe
may even be considered a witch's
familiar or as one South African told me
their sidekick but this is no Batman and
Robin situation the Tokoloshe carries
out any work the witches hesitate to do
themselves for fear of retaliation in
one version of the legend the Tokoloshe
carries a magic stone
charm that makes it invisible to
everyone but the witch who it is bound
to they cause misery in all kinds of
ways like giddy you fired causing bad
dreams stealing livestock or committing
sexual assault I couldn't find a
reliable source that explains why the
Tokoloshe myth came into existence in
the first place though it is part of
many African mythologies it's like the
boogeyman or any strange figure that
appears in the night how the Tokoloshe
is made is also debated within different
communities each having their own story
some say they were once a domestic
animal transforms by a witch or that
they were even the witch themselves
others say they are made from graveyard
dirt and parts of dead bodies or
sometimes even a doll it's also claimed
that the witch inserts a hot poker or
nail into the Tokoloshe as head to
animate it sangoma Musa fook-la told me
that he's not sure how one is made
because only witches know the exact
recipe however the Tokoloshe is
definitely made by someone practicing
dark magic so not only does it cause
evil in the lives of its victims it's
created with bad intentions
and while the Tokoloshe is smart and
capable of making its own decisions more
often than not it's following someone
else's orders because of that there's
not a whole lot you can do to avoid a
Tokoloshe as harassment since they are
small and supposedly bad climbers some
people put bricks under their beds to
elevate it and protect them from the
grasp of the Tokoloshe once you are
plagued with one only a single ma can
rid you of the creature the misdeeds of
the Tokoloshe vary widely but where it
gets truly unsettling is how they might
very well at the escape goat for actual
crime
in the early 1990s three pediatric
doctors reported that multiple children
came into their offices with sewing
needles inserted into their bodies their
mothers all said that this had been done
by a Tokoloshe
the doctors speculated that the children
were actually abused by their caregivers
who were often female neighbors or
relatives but by saying their children
have been harmed by a Tokoloshe the
mothers were able to seek health care
for their children without alienating or
upsetting their community relationships
in the past and in rural areas the
Tokoloshe has been more of a mischievous
trickster
but as urban spaces expanded the monster
took on the role of a violent sexual
predator a victim of assault might seek
help from a sangoma without fear of
retaliation from their attacker if the
victim frames the Tokoloshe
as the aggressor both of these examples
show how a fictional creature can be
more than just a scary story when
problems arise and crimes occur
unfortunately it can sometimes be easier
and even safer to point the finger at a
fictional being toe collages are symbols
of inappropriate and sometimes violent
sexual appetites mischief makers and a
possible vengeance of practitioners of
magic not all monsters have easy to
identify origins sometimes they have
taken on such a life of their own that
no amount of scholarly research can
pinpoint their creation and that's part
of what makes the Tokoloshe scary like
the boogeyman the malicious Tokoloshe
feeds off some of the most frightening
fears we have lurking in the night do
you have a favorite monster or myth you
would like to see on the show let me
know in the comments and don't forget to
subscribe do you have a favorite monster
man the hands first off but where it
gets truly up settling up settling
further not okay it's cute